[Music]
I actually would like to start off by
saying that I don't regard the tradition
that I've been in for all my life the
Labour Party in Britain as having
anything to do with Stalinism or what
happened in the Soviet Union I'm a
Democratic Socialist and I think that
the vision that I have it is a five
values for the way that we renew
socialism in our country and those
values in no particular order are
Liberty democracy equality cooperation
and internationalism and I don't think
Stalinism had a lot to do with any of
that and so I think the only future for
socialism is as Democratic socialists
within a democratic system arguing that
what I call in the book not
neoliberalism because that liberalism
sounds like a good thing I argue in the
book that we've suffered from 40 years
of market fundamentalism a
fundamentalist belief that markets are
the only way to make any decision that
the price mechanism is the only way to
choose any priority and that somehow you
cannot have the collective intervention
via an empowering state to create a
society that's more civilized where
people have more opportunities that's
fairer that achieves liberation for
women for people with disabilities for
avoid prejudice and discrimination
against people who were in the minority
the kind of society that I've always
wanted to build as a socialist so I
think we have to get away from this idea
that there's an authoritarian
anti-democratic democratic centralist
sort of Russian Communist way to Annie
Ivana that's always been a dead end and
when the Berlin Wall fell that was the
end of that kind of communistic view in
my
and so we've got to forge a different
way and that's about how we transform a
society that is a democracy with a
functioning market by putting the market
in its proper place and asserting the
primacy of a collective vision of the
direction we want our societies going
for motivates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you